the thermite reaction which is the
reaction of aluminium and iron oxide is
used to make iron and because aluminium
has much stronger bonds to oxygen than
iron that the reaction produces an
enormous amount of heat and you can use
this for welding pieces of metals
together so this is a thermite mixture
it's a mixture of iron oxides and
aluminium powder and we're going to do
redox chemistry and we're going to
generate some molten iron which will
hopefully stream from the bottom of the
of the flower pot so here you can see
the black particles of the iron oxide
and the silver particles of the
aluminium powder so we get some heat on
this we start an instantaneous redox
reaction so the aluminium and the and
the iron oxide swap oxygens so the
aluminium will become oxidized the iron
will become reduced hopefully will
generate a lot of molten iron which
should come from the bottom of the test
tube of the of the flower pod right now
there's a story about students in
Berkeley that some students decided or
group of students decided to do a
practical joke on the tram which of the
sort that has one door when you go in
and another one where you go out so big
group of students chill down to the tram
and got into the front and there were
enough of them so that they could
actually come out at the end at the
other door and form a loop so they were
just going round and round and round so
the tram couldn't leave because they
were just more and more people getting
on
good rather tight and while they were
doing this other students went down
under the tram and set off to thermite
reactions and welded the wheels metal
wheels of the tram to the steel rail so
that when the tram tried to leave when
the students eventually stopped going
round and round it was firmly welded to
the tracks and couldn't move at all it's
gone
taught me so much going on that so
instantly the thermite reaction starts
and you can see that it's so hot it's
burn a hole through the bottom of that
terracotta flowerpot but if we go in
close no Brady you can see all that
really quite nice molten iron now that's
so hot that the iron itself is melted
and it's formed it's really quite big
ooh in the bottom on the on the sand do
you encourage these sort of practical
jokes no no no no no our students are
far more responsible so as soon as the
firework or the sparkler hit the top of
the thermite reaction in the top of here
it started off the instantaneous redox
reaction so this was where the metals
were fighting for the oxygen the
aluminium won that battle and the
aluminium came out of this reaction as
aluminium oxide the iron was reduced and
we can see that now in the bottom which
is really hot so I'm not going to get
too close but you can see all of this
really really hot iron so the iron was
molten it dribbled out through the
bottom of the flower pot and it's now
cooling so you dribble out the bottom of
the flower pot well it it smashed its
way out of the flower pot well you can
say that iron is in my blood it's in
your blood as well it's iron that gives
hemoglobin the red pigment in your blood
it's red color so the reaction we saw
was about five minutes ago
and the iron that was generated is still
glowing red hot and you can see it's
fusion itself to the bottom half of it
of the the flower pot which which it
broke in its tumultuous step forward it
is an absolutely central molecule to
lower element to life except for crabs
which use copper but you'll have to hear
about that later so two iron ions a
really really abundant metal which is
used as lots and lots of structural
material so you can see lots of pieces
of iron around some of the racking and
even in fact some of these pieces of
equipment have got high iron content
they've got other elements mixed with
them to form alloys like stainless steel
I have an extremely long-standing
interested in its chemistry and
particular I made one compound of iron
so called and tetra carbonyl which had
four groups around it and everybody had
expected
that it would have a shape like one of
these shaped with tetrahedron like that
whereas in fact it turned out that it
had a much more irregular shape the four
groups were arranged like this and so
ever since this every time might hear
the word iron and get quite excited so
this is iron wire okay and you can see
this is a very small wire it's 0.2 of a
millimeter in diameter and you can see
the shiny material underneath is iron
that hasn't undergone oxidation so this
is where it's been protected from the
oxygen in the air now if we look at the
iron at the top we can see this looks
really familiar especially because it
looks like the rust that we might find
on the bottom side of some of our cars
so here's some iron oxide on top of the
iron the very first chemical experiment
I did was chemical reaction was with
iron and I think the same is true for
many generations of school children i
heated that iron and sulfur together and
made iron sulphide sort of blackish
solid but then we put acid on it and got
a terrible smell of bad eggs and this
was my introduction to chemistry and I
really loved it